Now, after we've gone through and cleaned our data, we're
at a place where we need to get the data
into MongoDB. So, we've looked at queries to MongoDB and
you've done some exercises. Let's look at inserting documents into
collections. Now, the database we've been working with all along
has been the examples database, and we've looked at a
couple of different collections here. We've looked at the autos
collection. We've also done some queries against the cities collection.
Now this script that we're looking at here is actually the
script that I wrote to clean the automobiles data. The way
that I originally wrote this was that it would simply output
JSON documents that I could then import into MongoDB. And that's actually
the, the strategy that I would recommend. But I think it's
also important for you to have an understanding of inserting documents
Into MongoDB. And so, we'll take this opportunity to show you
a little bit about how to do that. Now, there's a lot
about the insert statement that I'm not going to cover
right here. But, this is the simplest form of using
insert. Now, what we're going to do is simply loop through
all of the autos that I've created up here in
the code. Where I've cleaned the data and essentially created
a dictionary for each auto that needs to be inserted
into a MongoDB collection. Then we're going to simply loop
through the list of those autos that I've created and call
the insert statement for each one of them. Passing it
a Python dictionary, PyMongo will translate this into a BSON
encoding and send it across to the database. Now, what
I've got here, is I've just got a couple of print
statements. One that's going to demonstrate how many autos there
are before we do this series of inserts and one that's
going to show how many there are after. Now to
do this, I'm using a command we haven't looked at before,
but I'm sure you can figure out what it does. Simply tells us
how many documents were returned for this
find command. Okay now, let's run this.
Okay. So, what happened was, we went ahead and
inserted all of those documents that we had parsed out
of the CSV file from DBpedia for autos. Then what
I did was check the collection, this myautos collection, before
I did the inserts and got a count of how
many were in it. There were none. After doing all
my inserts, I have close to 7800 documents in this,
myautos collection now. So again, this is an example of
the insert command in MongoDB, one way of getting documents into the database.